bonjour je vous aider nous sommes
rippert café un lieu où on peut faire
réparer ces appareils électroniques et
autres en buvant un café ou un thé
mais attention ici vous participez à la
préparation de vos appareils et on va
faire un diagnostic si vous voulez
monsieur
l'atelier de greg qu'il partage avec
reynolds un autre technicien occupé avec
le téléphone portable d'une jeune
cliente
il a trouvé la panne hild explique ce
qu'il faut faire pour ne plus avoir de
tracas à l'avenir au fait on a
réinitialisé le téléphone parce qu'il
avait eu un problème de l'adresse mail
du coup ils avaient bloqué et l'on la
réinitialiser pour pouvoir le débloquer
et mettre son attention pour que le
téléphone soit à jour dans cette
association éco mobile situé au bourg du
lamentin
on vous apprend à comprendre le problème
de vos appareils et donc à réparer vous
même quand c'est possible je montre aux
personnes comment en fait j'ai
sensibilisé personnes sûres
le maintien en bon état des appareils
parce que souvent ils savent pas faire
voilà enfin disons un mauvais usage
jours on fait un peu de rééducation
division des appareils qui rentre une
télé qui s'en va c'est le quotidien ici
hors hyper café j'ai reçu la mauvaise
pièce commandée par internet
voilà donc ça repart je recommande une
pièce et je vais revenir la faire
réparer la volonté aussi c'est que les
gens soient acteurs de la réparation et
comprennent le fonctionnement le
dysfonctionnement de l'appareil afin
d'éviter qu'ils ne tombent en panne donc
bien souvent ce sont des problèmes
d'entretien des appareils poussière etc
qui fait que les appareils tombent en
panne au pays et quand même
alors oui il ya une participation qui
est demandé à tous un nom qui est de 5
euros pour un diagnostic et à partir de
5 euros sous forme de don lorsque la
réparation peut être fait et puis le
coin récup marlène la couturière
fabrique aujourd'hui des sacs cabas
grâce à des banderoles publicitaires
offerte par des entreprises ou des
voiles de bateau elle aussi est très
demandé des fois les clients c'est
surtout les retoucheurs une fermeture
knowledge in une robe de trollage une
robe trop série et enfin le dernier
atelier des bicyclettes ici on leur
donne une seconde chance leur hyper café
un lieu vraiment pleine vie